go tomorrow no animals boonton Martin
moosh is a man of ideas he helped put
together Hannah was application for the
creative city's Network a cultural
project sponsored by UNESCO he's also
launched a number of successful
advertising and publicity campaigns he's
lived in Hanover for 25 years now
enough a school stuff comin over is
large enough to have a lot to offer but
small enough so that it's easy to get
around it's just one of the appealing
things about the city and why I love it
so much plus there's culture cinema
music theatre it's all here music start
at the artist at for his first
recommendation merge takes us to the
shower house one of Germany's most
celebrated theaters that's a fly on over
I spent many evenings each year at the
Java House Hanover the theater is a gem
of modern architecture and it also puts
on quite unconventional productions but
there's also one section that looks
quite traditional let's take a look
right next door we find the cumberland
show gallery which features one of the
city's loveliest staircases the building
once housed an art gallery originally
built in the late 19th century it was
named after the Duke of Cumberland he
was the last Crown Prince of the kingdom
of Hanover and I mannequins one of my
absolute favorite spots in Hanover an
old staircase imbued with a wonderful
morbid charm it's also a theatre venue
where smaller shall be house productions
are staged small experimental pieces
where young directors can let their
imaginations run wild it's well worth a
visit whistle fat
Emma Nolan and as long as we're here
let's take a look at the Art Society the
quince fine and the building known as
the artists house right next door the
art society was founded by the residents
of Hanover more than a hundred and
eighty years ago
today it's an important exhibition
center for modern and experimental art
next we go outdoors and pay a visit to
the elegant Baroque era heaven hulls and
Gardens recently reopened the Heron
house and Palace is now a museum one
exhibition features a philosopher
quadfeed feel home Leibniz a brilliant
man of letters lightness spent many
years in Hanover and helped plan the
gardens but an eyeball the Heron house
impala's has been rebuilt and the garden
ensemble has been restored to its former
glory now the site once again brings
together horticulture and gardening with
the Arts and Sciences just as it did
originally and just as lighten its would
have wanted doesn't often gets to that
saddam his third tip is a real treat the
holland ishika couch to the cafe has
been an attraction in hanover for about
a hundred and twenty years now oh the
raspberry Gatto looks especially
delicious today many locals say this is
where to find Hanover's best cakes and
hot chocolate it's even famous outside
Germany the cafe has branches in Osaka
and Tokyo
ian is shocked at how spoke with a
Hollander Shekau scuba embodies solidity
in the very best sense of the word I
love coming here to read and to let my
thoughts drift a bit there's a lovely
cafe tradition here in the city I came
here as a child with my grandparents and
I still enjoy coming here that's kindred
mangoes Adam won't be beside sir galahad
the cafe opens at 9am but it's closed on
Sundays and now we've seen Martin most
three tips for visitors to Hanover you
want to discover Germany welcome to our
website for more information and
inspiration concerning your trip to
Germany visit our website at DW de
forward slash visit Germany here you can
also watch discover Germany your
favorite travel show visit Germany
whenever you want and wherever you are
by clicking on DW de forward slash visit
Germany
you
you